-Good evening.
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
Former president Trump
testified yesterday
at his civil fraud trial
and spent nearly four hours
on the witness stand.
But the judge
had to call it a day
before they could ask him
a third question.
[ Laughter ]
During his testimony yesterday,
former president Trump
pulled a piece of paper
out of his suit jacket
that he claimed
would clear his name,
but the judge would not
let him read it
'cause, as usual,
it was classified.
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
during his civil fraud trial,
Trump pulled a piece of paper
out of his suit jacket
and said it would
completely clear his name.
Dude, you couldn't have
cleared your name
if you'd pulled out a neuralyzer
from "Men in Black."
What piece of paper
could possibly clear your name?
Was it a birth certificate
with a different name?
[ As Trump ] Your Honor,
this clears my name because,
as you can see,
my name is Reginald Periwinkle.
You've got the wrong guy.
[ Normal voice ] Ivanka Trump
is set to testify tomorrow
as part of the civil fraud trial
against former president Trump,
marking -- making it, excuse me,
the first thing she's been
invited to in New York
in eight years.
[ Laughter ]
Democrats -- Have her
over to your house.
Feel so bad about it.
Democrats reportedly
have concerns
about President Biden's
reelection campaign
and are worried that
his political advisers
are ignoring warning signs
of sinking support.
Said Biden, "There's nothing
to worry about, right, Jill?
Jill?!"
Amid reports that he has
declined an invitation
to attend King Charles's
75th birthday party,
a spokesperson for Prince Harry
said that he never
received an invite,
or, more likely,
Meghan got the mail that day.
[ Laughter ]
Guys, let me tell you something.
I don't think either
of them get the mail.
[ Laughter ]
Elon Musk's brain implant
company, Neuralink,
has announced that
it's looking for volunteers
for human testing.
Well, actually, what they said
was "fresh volunteers."
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
Musk's brain implant company
has announced it's looking for
volunteers for human testing.
I don't think he should be
meddling with something
he doesn't really understand,
like humans.
[ Laughter ]
The co-work--
I love what he did with Twitter.
I'd love to get him
up in my brain.
[ Laughter ]
Love to get him up there
to fiddle around.
Now it's not called
the brain anymore.
It's called B.
[ Laughter ]
The co-working space
company WeWork
filed yesterday for bankruptcy.
Wait a minute.
Again?
You already went
out of business.
I watched a whole miniseries
about how you went
out of business,
and you were still in business?
Oh, my God, Trump's going to win
again, isn't he?
According to a new study,
daily marijuana use
could increase the risk
of a heart attack.
And that's why I only
smoke it nightly.
[ Laughter ]
Using my B.
The CDC announced yesterday
it will expand
its airport disease
surveillance program
to include
more than 30 pathogens.
Cool. I think I know where
you can find 27 of them.
[ Audience groans ]
The makers --
You guys all got feet.
[ Laughter ]
Everybody's like, "Oh, feet,
a human foot.
I would never."
The makers of M&M's
have unveiled
a new holiday flavor,
Toasty Vanilla,
which features
white chocolate candies
coated in brown,
white, and vanilla shell.
It's the holiday treat
that will have everyone saying,
"Do you have any normal ones?"
[ Laughter ]
And finally, according
to the latest numbers,
Taylor Swift's new album
"1989 (Taylor's Version)"
has sold 1.6 million units
in the U.S.,
and it's made her
almost 8 cents on Spotify.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And that was the monologue,
everybody.
We're off and running.
We got a great show
for you tonight.
She hosts the Emmy-winning
"Rachel Maddow Show"
Monday nights on MSNBC,
and her book "Prequel: An
American Fight Against Fascism"
is a page-turner.
It's out now.
The one and only Rachel Maddow
is back on the show.
[ Cheers and applause ]
He's a Grammy-winning musician,
front man of one of my all-time
favorite bands, Wilco.
His book "World Within a Song:
Music That Changed My Life
and Life That Changed My Music"
is out now.
Jeff Tweedy is back
and joining us.
Very excited about that.
You guys, this summer,
I did a podcast
called "Strike Force Five"
with the other talk show hosts,
and when the topic of favorite
guest came up, I had one name.
She's here tonight.
You can catch her on tour now,
and also her new show,
"Ms. Pat Settles It,"
is everything you want it to be.
Ms. Pat is back, everybody.
Quite the show.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Speaking of
the great Jeff Tweedy,
he was also kind enough
to record a jingle
for the podcast I'm doing
with my brother,
"Family Trips with
the Meyers Brothers."
We talk to people about
the trips they took
when they were kids,
the trips they're taking now.
This week, just released today,
the great Nick Offerman.
So do check out "Family Trips"
wherever you get your podcasts.
Moving on,
we here at "Late Night"
don't always have enough time
to cover all of the recent news.
So here with a recap
is one of our writers,
Amber Ruffin, in a segment
we call "Amber Says What."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hey.
You guys,
things have been crazy.
Okay, first of all,
I heard 80-year-old actor
Robert De Niro just had a child,
and I was like, "What?"
Then I heard 83-year-old
Al Pacino also just had a child,
and I was like, "What?"
What old man is going
to have a toddler next, Seth?
[ Laughter ]
-I do have a toddler.
-Gross. How?
-The normal way.
-Ew!
-Why don't you have a child?
-Because I am a child.
A sexy little child.
[ Tink! ]
Then I heard that
they arrested Tupac's killer,
and I was like, "What...
is next on your to-do list?
Get a warrant
for John Wilkes Booth?"
You're late!
Why not figure out
who shot J.R.?
-Oh, it was Kristin Shepard.
-You are so old.
-I'm only five years
older than you.
-I don't like this anymore.
Then I heard that Ron DeSantis
wears secret high-heeled boots,
and I was like, "Wh-ha-ha-at?"
You must hate being short more
than you hate drag queens.
Speaking of drag queens,
with those high heels,
you are one sew-in away
from violating
your own anti-trans bill, honey.
Then I read that all of
Trump's kids are testifying,
and I was like, "What?!"
Ivanka, Don Jr., Eric.
All the kids.
Man, I think
he might go to jail.
Now, I know, I know,
he may be rich,
he may be old,
and he may be a white man,
but -- oops, never mind,
he will never go to jail.
He'll probably just do what all
the other old guys are doing --
have a baby, which I believe
to be a prison in its own right.
Okay, so then I heard En Vogue
is going to be in the
Macy's Thanksgiving Day Parade.
I was like, "What?!"
And I have to say this.
Please, NBC, corporate daddy,
you have to let me in
to see that.
Oh, Seth, do you have tickets
to the parade?
-No.
-Then what is the point of you?
Why are we doing this?
What is any of this for
if it's not going to help us
see En Vogue?
Then Britney Spears
released her memoir,
"The Woman in Me," and spilled
the tea on Justin Timberlake.
And I was like, "Wh-ha-aaaat?"
It's, like, a lot,
and I don't know if I'm allowed
to talk about what she said,
but let's just say this.
Now, do you want to hear
some more gossip?
Okay, so,
Congressman George Santos
was running around his job
with a baby,
and I was like, "What?"
When asked if the baby was his,
he said, "Not yet."
[ Laughter ]
Which brings us to a segment
called "Amber Says Why."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now, George Santos said
this baby wasn't his yet.
Why? Yet? Is that a threat?
And if so, to who?
To me? America?
Whoever's baby that is?
What?
Whose baby is that and why?
Why the baby, George?
Why did they give
their baby to you?
Did you trick somebody
and steal their baby?
Where did you get
that baby from?
Does it want to go back?
Did you ever give the baby back?
Why the baby, George?
For what reason?
What purpose was the baby
supposed to serve?
And did it serve that purpose?
And why does that baby
look more qualified
to work in Congress than you?
This has been "Amber Says Why."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Then I read that Beyoncé's
"Renaissance" tour
made $579 million.
[ Audience cheers ]
Me too, man.
It made so much money,
it literally boosted the economy
everywhere it went.
I read that and I was like...
because I'm not about to mess up
the Beyoncé mute challenge.
Mnh-mnh.
Then I saw that Beyoncé
went to the premiere
of Taylor Swift's new movie,
and I was like, "What?!"
Beyoncé is not at
a Taylor Swift premiere.
A Taylor Swift premiere
is at a Beyoncé.
And I can't even imagine
what Beyoncé in a movie theater
looks like.
Walking up to
the concession stand like,
"I will have the Sugar Babies
and a bottle of Cristal."
Then...
[ Laughter ]
It came out so much worse.
Then I heard there were
a million bedbugs in Paris,
and I was like, "Quoi?"
Then I found out Usher was doing
the Super Bowl halftime show,
and I was like, "What!"
Well, I guess I'm going to
have to cook him
a real big breakfast
that morning.
Not because
I'm sleeping with him,
but because I had to take on
an extra job as Usher's cook
'cause the writers' strike
lasted five months.
Then I found out the actors
were still striking,
and I was like, "What?"
Matter of fact, Seth,
how am I allowed to be
doing this right now?
-Well, late-night television
shows fall under a specific --
-Ohh! Shut up.
Then I heard that genetic
testing company 23andMe
was hacked, and I was like,
"What...were you thinking
when you gave away all
your genetic information
to some random company?"
See, that's why
I never did 23andMe.
Well, that and in case
I ever want to do a murder.
I want to get away with it.
Then I heard
Congresswoman Lauren Boebert
got kicked out
of the musical "Beetlejuice"
for getting felt up by some guy.
And I was like, "What?!"
"Beetlejuice"?
More like "Some Like It Hot."
"Some Like It Hot,"
co-written by Amber Ruffin,
now on Broadway
at the Shubert Theatre.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Boebert, why would you guys
stay in your seats for that?
At least escape to the bathroom
and pretend
you're taking a whiz.
"The Wiz,"
written by Amber Ruffin,
touring America and coming
to Broadway March 29th.
Tickets available
at wizmusical.com.
-Hey, Amber, why do you
keep interrupting this bit
to plug all
your Broadway musicals?
-Because the strike
took too long,
and I got to make money
to take care of this baby.
-Amber, is that your baby?
-Not yet.
[ Tink! ]
This has been "Amber Says What."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Amber Ruffin, everybody.
We'll be right back
with Rachel Maddow.